I want to thank the president of France
Nicolas Sarkozy for being such a
terrific friend I want to thank his wife
met him Sarkozy they just hosted us at
the palace and could not have been more
gracious cordial I'm feeling dizzy
an economist of the Mercatus Center at
George Mason University
by all accounts President Obama had a
great time while traveling recently in
my native country of France and he had
many flattering things to say about
Gallic healthcare cuisine and high-speed
railroads but it is is whether more
crushed on the French way of doing
things extends to economic policies the
result will be nothing less than a train
wreck
as elite opinion urges and encourages
Obama to become more French by
increasing spending and taxes and
regulation we would all be better off if
the president does exactly the opposite
French economists might have coined the
terms ELISA fair and entrepreneur but
any comparison of the French and US
systems plainly shows that the American
Way makes everyone better off over the
past thirty years the French economy
average 1.9 percent annual growth while
the US economy grew by an average of 2.9
percent as a result Americans are far
wealthier with a per capita income of
$45,000 versus $33,000 to the French
lower taxes in America also mean that we
keep more of our income French labor
policies make it far more expensive to
hire and fire workers with a predictable
result that unemployment has always been
significantly higher in the land of
heavy metal or massive strikes that
routinely shut down the entire country
these very different outcomes are not
due to differences in natural resources
or individual ability the basic reason
is that the French govern
spends too much of the country's money
makes it too expensive for businesses to
hire and fire workers and then taxes
those lucky enough to have jobs our
trades that leave them precious few
euros with which to leave libelous or
the good life President Obama as someone
who was born in Paris raised in Normandy
and educated at the Sorbonne I can
totally understand the appeal of French
art culture and savoir vivre or the
French way of doing things but please
understand that it's one thing to visit
France and it's a whole other thing
actually live there